after an age of the cruelest tyranny  man finally defeated its overlord  the gods do not fall  forever  the champions of war united  and began the eternal watch over their  tyrant's colossal remains  for some forces  even death  cannot end  but now eons later  the fallen gods influence pervades the  world again  corrupting even sworn enemies  to join his accursed lords of the fallen  and damn humanity  to a new age of devastation  though from these darkest days  new heroes arise  to defy the gods one must embrace the  darkness  and so lies our only hope  [Music]  mother  tell your children not to work my way  tell your children not to hear my words  [Music]  what it's like  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  me  the lords of the fallen  wish list now  you